thanks for having me on your show again
yeah
so this one i had i had to come in okay
here here's the thing with the blank
code
okay i don't even know
the black pill i don't i don't know what
they talk about
i don't know
who the influences are but one thing i
can tell you
is that it can't be anything good and
here's why
because for a long time
i
i have always been red pill
i have always kind of noticed
that
you know there's a schism in society
where
it's almost like walking in the twilight
zone
where everybody else is plugged in
and for a long time i was engaging in a
lot of communities
that were just
so plugged in
even bringing up
red pill
ideas of like
you know hey
we're talking about equality but then
why
why is all like i don't see where
there's equality i don't see where this
inclusion is
you know i don't see if if you ask these
people to actually live up to the values
of diversity inclusion and equity
you know
they themselves fall short okay so
without getting like you know tied up in
that
and so a lot of my anger and frustration
before
was trying to even make people aware of
what i was seeing and i was not
understood by these people and i have
been i have lost friends lifelong
friends actually from sharing one of
your posts
on facebook
where
you know
it was like
90 of relationships would end if the guy
lost his job oh yeah that one's super
triggering yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
his so i got into an argument
with you know the guy's girlfriend and
then it just blew up and just went crazy
but why did they get back why do they
get mad because it's true people only
get people like the closer you get to
the truth the louder they screech is
what i've learned
okay and the other thing that i've
learned is people don't want to hear
your opinion they don't want your
opinion they want their opinion coming
out of your mouth
so would you recommend
going through the world
and just and applying that as like a
tactic to just kind of navigate the
world
and then we live in a
i don't know how
how old are you
31.
okay so i mean you're a bit younger than
me you're almost 20 years younger than
me um so
here's what i've seen
you know when i was a kid it was sticks
and stones hurt you know could hurt my
or sorry was it sticks and stones may
hurt my bones but words will never hurt
me
that was one of the lyrics that they
taught us or it was
uh i'm rubber and you're glue and what
you say bounces off me and sticks to you
okay so that's how they taught kids back
then to deal with
words that's how they taught us to deal
with like you know things that might not
be politically correct or might be
hurtful
today now it's like words are terrorism
or like words are violence
and it's like you can't say anything
without offending somebody so
you know i just take a look at it i'm
like okay i understand the way things
are i am not going to fight that i don't
care you know if you guys want to burn
it down if you all want to be a bunch of
[ __ ] and that's cool
um my life is sorted i'm good and you
guys just carry on you know sucking each
other off it's it's all good
really just have to learn how to
surrender to certain things in life i
think surrendering is a very useful
skill for guys to understand and i've
talked about it from time to time on my
channel i've even dedicated i believe
one or two videos on
you know like on that topic so once you
see it for what it is like why why waste
your energy fighting it
it's pointless
well for certain groups do you kind of
uh
do do you find yourself keeping them
like at a distance so for example
there's something like a group that i
hang out with because it's convenient
you know it's it's fun to pass the time
with them but then they're not my real
friends like my real friends are mma
fighters uh blue-collar workers or
successful in business okay so i mean
you just name three different categories
and the five closest people should be
the ones that matter to you you know the
most so why do you care about these
other people
because
they will they my good friends
they don't live nearby
so like the people that i spend time
with
i mean
okay but are these people that are
trying to impose their opinions and
beliefs on you that you don't agree with
like are they the people that are trying
to hear their opinion coming out of your
mouth
yeah actually you just said it perfectly
[ __ ] them who cares
like
as you get older you are going to change
the people that you surround yourself
with you're not gonna like i'm
i know one guy from high school
and i've seen him maybe like once in the
last five years he texts me like once
every few months
okay right it's like you know we need to
get you know get together we never do
because you know he's an entrepreneur
he's got kids i've got a kid i got
business that i got to do i got things
that i do so your past just may never
cross ever again like you never really
know it doesn't really matter it's it's
not that significant right you know your
circle of influence will change there's
there's this old saying reason season
lifetime like people come into your life
for a reason sometimes they come into
your life for season and there's others
that come into your life for a lifetime
that's okay you know sometimes people
show up to teach you a lesson sometimes
people show up you know to teach you
what you don't want to be around right
and there's others that may be around
for an entire lifetime um you just have
to understand that if somebody around
you is like an energy vampire and
they're exhaustive you know like i don't
know how guys watch negative content
loser content that's like oh you're a
loser you're always going to be a loser
you're not good-looking enough you're
never making enough money you know the
elite rich have all the money and the
you know the dac stack stacked up
against you and uh you know it's it's
this culture is this religion that's got
all the money or something like that
it's like
you know what let them believe that that
that just makes it easier for me to be
successful that just makes it easier for
me to get what i want that makes it
easier for me to get more girls if
that's what i want right
so
you have to be okay with leaving people
behind like you have to prune to grow if
that makes sense
well that's a great way to put it um
when you come
i'm kind of getting to the point where
like modern life dating i heard him
speaking like
last week about something
it was about being
extremely successful
with women
to the point that
okay so i still have this
urge right and i identify with what he
said because a lot of
a lot of men
probably just want to be in a meaningful
relationship
and that's you know i think that's
pretty normal
um
but then you know for someone like me
i'm not an insult
you know like
if i if i if i
try to explain to my
some of my friends
they think i'm like some insult guy but
i'm not
you know you could go i could go on my
phone right now show you
um
but
they
it's
i like i'm not an intel but i still have
this urge like i i have this urge to
find
a girl
or you know
almost like this this
life comes full circle
when you finally find that one and i'm
struggling with this
because
so let me speak to that because i
because i want to get to this one other
guy here that's in the background before
i wrap up so i had a conversation with a
um a guy over the weekend and um
you know he said um he basically said
yeah i'm looking for a girl to move in
and i said why
he said well
because that's what you're supposed to
do right you know i think that would be
cool to make my life easier i said well
why
and i asked him why like three times
like every time you know he answered i
just kept saying why maybe like three or
four times then it got to the point like
he started to realize
okay well that's not really i don't
really have an answer as to why i've
just been told my entire life that
that's what i should be doing so i'm 34
so why don't i have this by now like i'm
doing something wrong like you know i've
i've got to achieve this goal to get to
where i want it's like
no you don't
you don't at all right i mean i mean if
you take a look at your entire family
and
um you know i knew a good chunk of um
family around all those conversations
there like there's not a lot of people
that are living together in long-term
relationships that are like ecstatic to
be around each other i you know i can
count maybe on one hand everybody that i
know in my inner circle um that i would
say is in a very happy productive
long-term relationship and you start to
realize okay well maybe the goal isn't
having a girl move in maybe the goal is
if you reframe it to something like
being the absolute best version of
myself like being a weapon
so that i can choose who i may or may
not want to invite into my life on a
long-term basis or a short-term basis or
you know with multiple women at the same
time it doesn't matter you can do
whatever the hell you want but the point
being is
reframe the question
more towards mental point of origin and
less towards conformity to what the
societal narrative has always been which
is live with a girl have her move in
make babies and you know live happily
ever after whatever
because that doesn't usually play out
you've read my book right
yeah and actually i loaned it to my
buddy too so
does that make
sense yeah
all right keep asking questions man
yeah for sure all right i'll see you
there thank you peace
you